- So you're not gonna believe
what the QShaman's lawyer
said in an interview,
or you probably will believe what he said.
Albert Watkins, the
lawyer for the Qshaman,
said, "A lot of these defendants,
and I'm going to use this colloquial term,
perhaps disrespectfully,
but they're all (beep) short bus people.
These are people with brain damage.
They're (beep).
They're on the (beep) spectrum."
Now, Watkins is an
incredibly infamous attorney
in his own right.
The first line of his bio says that he is,
"quite frankly, beyond description."
Now, I don't know if that's true,
but one description you might
not use is "good lawyer"
because just because
you're on the spectrum
doesn't mean you can't tell the difference
between right and wrong.
So that's not a defense for
his client or anyone else,
and Watkins went on to say,
"They're part of our country.
They aren't bad people.
They don't have a prior
criminal history (beep).
They were subjected to four-plus
years of (beep) propaganda,
the likes of which the world has not seen
since (beep) Hitler."
Interesting move to go after clemency
while being about as
offensive as possible.
Now, that probably won't help
in terms of establishing guilt.
It might help in terms of sentencing
to try and get less
sentencing for the crimes
that they will be convicted of.
But, you know, I guess you
defend the clients that you have,
not the clients that you want.
So we will definitely
see all of them in court.